with some waffle fries how's some waffle
fries why you say so aggressively what
the [ __ ] is wrong hey hey I think Philly
is different if you don't get waffle
fries that's just unforgivable I'm sorry
huh waffle fries
[Music]
yeah I wanted to ask you yeah how much
money do you make
I don't know if you want to seem like
that
you know interested in like money and
stuff but stop
you don't want to seem like you you do
the minute you ask the question who we
think to ourselves something's off
hey I don't want to sound like a jerk
but how many guys did you [ __ ] with stop
stop
you asked
listen I've been on a lot of dates I've
never had anyone ask me that question
this is new to me I don't know if this
is common I don't know if people
actually do this [ __ ] but that's a lot
how much money do you make that's a wild
that's wild I would never answer that
question I wouldn't tell my friends how
much I make to me just opening up on
financial information that has nothing
to do with people you want my tax
information too what the [ __ ] is this
you know what's about that thing what
my girl's not sure how much I make she
don't need to know she don't but she
but she is every month she don't know
we good okay and then that's it you know
how we call that but I know how much you
make it Men In Black I flash myself with
that [ __ ] and I forget right afterwards
because it's none of my business I don't
even know how much my girl makes
it it doesn't matter
I know she gonna pay the bills oh I know
I want to pay so this is apparently some
kind of first statement that that's oh
no but that's off that's off that's
weird wait wait wait wait wait you're
going to date you go on a date the girl
says Abba
how much do you make I don't want to
sound like you know but how much do you
how much you make okay
your answer how what's what's the
etiquette
enlighten me me akibuster there's none
of your business that's what I would
tell her straight to her face but I
would have a good laugh about it just
because it has to be so off car you know
what like after you've been on enough
dates sometimes you're like entertained
like oh this [ __ ] is weird
because I'll be entertained even if I'm
not [ __ ] you know like I'm not gonna
lie
I would probably appreciate that I would
appreciate a lot more if you said listen
I like men with money so I need to know
how much you make I would I would find
that way more endearing and funny but uh
this I'd have a good laugh I I would
turn this date into
a troll
ey I I just I didn't at this point as a
troll
yeah I mean you gotta you got you gotta
you gotta you gotta play along a little
bit because you're no longer interested
I already biked over you know I put on
some cologne I showed up to the [ __ ] so
if she gonna ask me some crazy question
I'm gonna get my money's worth are you
gonna ask crazy questions too oh yeah
it's cool ass oh man listen what color
song you got on that's not crazy that is
crazy no go crazier no no that's crazy
go crazy on the first date go crazy I
could tell you I've been on many First
Dates no I haven't ladies yeah ladies
for my defense I told you from the jump
yeah that's a crazy question I told you
from the jump what circumstances do you
think is perfectly fine to be like yo
what color your underwear yo Wayne is
getting you know I mean exactly you're
about to find out you know what I mean
you guys had all this stuff it's the
first date you're not gonna ask that
I don't know
um
I get it maybe you don't want to take me
to the most fanciest place like on the
first date but never again are you gonna
think oh well next time next time
we're not even my girl
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know cheap restaurants
he took her to Applebee's
[Music]
okay there's this thing about first date
where you supposed to wow her
you supposed to you know I mean I've
heard the biggest
feminist talking about yeah you need to
you need to show up you need to show me
you know I mean I heard that you need to
show out he needs to bring me to a place
and you're gonna pay the bills I'm a
feminist but you gonna pay the bill yeah
yeah
so
hmm
you're never going to bring me again I'm
never gonna bring you nowhere period so
go go go go go get yourself your your
rich man and be alone by 50. go ahead
go ahead
I don't know how that finishes but
that's fine
it's weird
I've heard the biggest feminist be like
nah but you know if it's a first date
you need to wow me that's okay it's like
I don't know how I feel about that
listen we want to record it doesn't
matter if I'm this or not they just want
to record it's normal
that's what they expect we can say
whatever they want at this point it just
doesn't matter they want to be courted
as far as taking her to Applebee's
I mean honestly that's an L just because
like you got some shitty ass taste
Applebee's is trash I'm judging you for
that I mean it would really depend if
they were having a conversation about
going to some nice place for dinner you
take her to Applebee's afterwards I
probably look at you sideways too
um if a girl took me on a date to
Applebee's I'd look at her sideways
not because it's cheap just kind of like
[ __ ] that's basic but if you want a
fast baked Starbucks for a first date is
not good
if we just going for coffee yeah that's
fine I could at least accept that
because it's just a coffee like it's
nothing you just you can grab water I
grab whatever's fine if you take me out
to dinner
making me doodle
I'ma look at you funny
I was like oh why don't we go to
McDonald's because I don't even know
that's trash I want you to yeah girl I
want you oh that's trash I first think
that's trash in her defense that's trash
Applebee's come on my [ __ ] that's trash
yeah
McDonald's like come on you gotta hold
the L for that that's a Taco Bell what
are we talking about right now that's
not even that's not even food
once y'all eat Taco Bell watching right
now I don't care that's not meat the
transfer fire okay
the fries with whatever the [ __ ] the
Supreme fries fire
but every time I eat that [ __ ] I didn't
think of moo I didn't think of cows that
was some some meat special
what about Chick-fil-A Hey listen the
girl could take me to Chick-fil-A or
anything Hey listen that's an exception
get me a classic chicken
with the with the Chick-fil-A sauce on
the side because you know a [ __ ]
gotta dip it and make that bun extra
crispy you already know
with some waffle fries that's some
waffle fries now you say so aggressively
what the [ __ ] is wrong hey hey I think
Philly is different if you don't get
waffle fries that's just unforgivable
I'm sorry huh waffle fries
[Music]
because of throwback shut up this
[ __ ] said that with the the
Buffalo fries the people who know no
okay but all I'm trying to say is this
it's kind of fire a first date
Applebee's imma look at you sideways so
I got in her defensive step but she's
Wilding for asking how much this money
for me
if you're not good with the day just say
that but don't be yeah you better not be
broke or poor and and you know what I
didn't like she said
because I know next time you ain't
nothing you ain't taking me no place
like this again
and it might happen [ __ ] how you know
that's gonna be a next time I ain't
taking you know where I mean if he took
you to Applebee's you know what it is
he's trying to hit it and quit it
next time ooh that's that's presumptuous
yeah but Bola you the thing that you
showed up to the interview thinking you
got the job yeah both of you the thing
that it was going to be over next time
you about to be on Tick Tock talk about
I hate men
I think you hate Applebee's and that's a
different problem okay I'm just saying
next time that's presumptuous
you should you do not seem like a happy
camera you know what else I noticed what
any [ __ ] who said she not a gold digger
but she got nails like hers
I ain't believing nothing
I'm mad at that something about them
long nails is just so goddamn nasty you
don't like the Click clickety clack bro
maybe I'll maybe maybe something wrong
with guys guys guys can we all talk
about it ain't them Nails always so
goddamn disgusting you don't like that
but anyways any thoughts you have about
that question
uh hey it's it's it's a major red flag
for me hey man it's a major red flag for
me that's so crazy
I don't know what that like
that's a major red flag
she feel business she was so
authoritative too yeah listen and I know
you know you want to take me to
Applebee's you don't want to take me
nowhere fancy but like this is
unacceptable
are you excluding me
this is the first time we're going on a
date and you were like scolding me
I don't know there's certain things
about that that's like off-putting but
Applebee's is a hard owl you've got to
hold that
peace
you ever been to Applebee's bro yeah
that's just trash it's like taking a
girl out to a [ __ ] Denny's it's like
America at 3 A.M I'll accept
because it's late America is Amigos
they won't understand the reference this
is true yeah but anyways let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below